James Cullen Bressack: I also find it interesting
as well on the flip side because my auto-dm
goes out [Automated Direct Message) and says
“Hey, check out my movies on Amazon.”
or whatever.
And I’ll get responses from all these people
around the world saying “Hey, I love your
movie.
I saw this one or that.”
And everyone is always responding saying ‘I
love them’ or ‘I’ve seen them.’
And my response is either A) A distributor
owes me a lot of money that I don’t know
about or B) (which I think is the more likely
one) is that things are probably getting downloaded
on the Internet a lot.
A perfect instance of piracy is a movie I
did…I won’t say which one but the first
month that it was out, it only shipped like
5,000 units.
And then I looked at one of those piracy websites
and it had something like 150,000 downloads.
And I was like “Wow!
If I only had like a dollar for every single
time that this happened, I’d be”…but
at least they’re watching them right?
Film Courage: I’m not advocating piracy
but do you think it can sometimes help someone’s
career or a project in some way?
James Cullen Bressack: I think sometimes.
I mean if you look at that movie INK, if you
saw that?
They actually released it for free online.
They encouraged the piracy of it.
So I think yes and no.
Personally I’m against piracy because I
think it’s stealing.
Legitimately stealing from the filmmaker.
And I know it’s kind of weird to say but
it’s like messed up to pirate stuff.
But if you’re going to pirate stuff, at
least don’t pirate the indie film.
Like the really low budget indie stuff, the
difference between one extra DVD and one extra
download is somebody rent that month, possibly.
So it’s like I feel for people because I
have a lot of friends that are at this and
haven’t really been doing well because of
piracy.
So I want people to understand that it really
does hurt the filmmaker.
It really does.
Film Courage: How do you think a lot of people
in your generation and slightly older feel
about this because they have gotten so much
for free on the Internet [to now put parameters
in place for force payment]?
How do they view it?
James Cullen Bressack: I mean the weird thing
about it is I will be talking to friends from
high school or childhood, elementary school
or whatever, people I’ve known for years
and years.
And I’ll be like “Hey, you should check
out my new movie.”
And they’ll be like “Oh, yeah.
Sure.
I’ll just download it.”
or they’ll be like “Oh yeah, I’ll watch
it on this website or whatever.”
And I’ll be like “You’re literally just
telling me you’re going to steal from me.”
Are you really just going to be like “Oh
yeah, I’m going to take $20.00 out of your
wallet.”
No!
But for some reason it’s so okay amongst
that…they actually think that it’s become
so part of the culture so that it’s fine
when it’s really not.
So if there is a way to monetize that, such
as if we release movies for free online with
ads on them or something, that is at least
better than having them stolen.
You look at those websites that have those
movies hosted for free and all this traffic
is driven to the website, they’re making
money on those sites because they are selling
ad space on those sites.
People are making a lot of money off of our
hard work.